China is currently experiencing the
largest mass migration ever witnessed in
human history. Over the past 30 years,
China's urban population has grown by
over half a billion people, thanks
largely to a vast exodus of peasants
from the countryside. And the Chinese
government is trying to speed this
influx through an official urbanization
drive, so as to bolster the country's
declining economic growth rate. In theory,
urbanization makes a lot of economic
sense: Urban workers tend to be more
productive. But in China, the domestic
migration comes with a big political
catch: the catch known as the hukou
system, an identification and
registration program utilized for social
control by the Ministry of Public
Security. In practice, most peasants who
move to urban areas for better jobs
keep their rural hukou, meaning they cannot
obtain urban social services, can't bring
their children along, earn less than
comparably skilled urban counterparts,
and face further discrimination, too. Sounds
almost like a apartheid-era South
Africa. Can such a repressive arrangement
really last forever?
What do you think is
China's most pressing population problem?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure
to like and subscribe for more research
and videos from AEI.